question tonight opens with would you
share your wife and your finances with
your wife's boyfriend as it states in
the description of the video now if
you're watching this uh Elsewhere on the
interwebs I would love it if you came
over and watch live here
uh there in the chat that's the link to
the unplugged Alpha YouTube channel head
on over subscribe hit the like button
all that good stuff
as as they say and as it goes uh let me
share real quick up here on the screen
these uh
tabs I got here so we've got
so this is the typical idea so if you
guys don't know what polyamorous means
or poly means
it's not what you think it is
usually when you hear this most guys are
like oh that means you're running a
harem and you have like Sister Wives or
you're or you're like dating a lot of
women simultaneously sort of thing or
maybe even living together with all
these women
that's what guys think it is but the
truth of the matter is today's version
is more or less
a couple of dorks or one dork or maybe
three dorks and one girl or two girls or
something like that and you're gonna see
what I'm talking about in a second when
we get to the meat and potatoes of it
all but first let's kind of deal with
what the media likes to sell us right so
this is the standard narrative right
here
okay uh it'll be an article with hey I'm
polyamorous and live with my partners
and our children here's how we make it
work and they like to amplify and
suggest that this is something that's
very easy and convenient in today's
world
um we'll talk about the convenience
factors and everything that sort of like
builds into this but in this image here
we've got a woman with two dudes kissing
her on the cheek for those of you that
are listening to the audio podcast
uh summary here says when my husband and
I opened up our relationship we never
thought we'd have a living partner I can
guarantee he didn't think this
that changed when we met Tai we moved in
together and along with our two kids and
never looked back here's how we parent
while we live in a polyamorous
relationship now this is this is them
selling the idea like it's supposed to
work it's supposed to be easy this by
the way is not how the unplugged Alpha
lives
um let's just read this through here
imagine a polyamorous person right now
you're probably thinking of a young
person who lives with their cats and
plants well some people are or maybe an
Instagram throuple where every member is
super fit and conventionally attractive
conventionally attractive you're gonna
you're gonna see when you start seeing
the photographs in the videos a little
bit
what sorry what about an exhausted mom
who wears yoga pants okay I've got two
kids D who's 11 H who's nine I also have
two living Partners there's Daniel my
legal spouse and the biological father
of D and H and Ty my unofficial spouse
and co-parent we're not a throuple
Daniel and Ty do not date each other but
I switched beds between the two so this
woman married a guy Daniel who's her
legal spouse and then convinced Daniel
to let Ty move into the equation
Daniel and I opened up our marriage into
translation she opened it up our kids
were six and three at the time we opted
to join a local polyamory group that was
family friendly and we brought our kids
to many could you imagine being one of
these kids in school
and the other kids find out that your
mom is getting blanked by some other
dude and your dad has to sleep in a
spare room
I'm gonna I'm gonna be doing a video on
bullying at some point in the future
because I've because I've got some
thoughts on that
um but back to the subject of polyamory
anyway so this couple brings their kids
to a polyamorous family meetup group or
something to help normalize it for my
kids at a young age because it's
apparently normalized now right we
didn't think we'd actually live together
with a partner I would be irresponsible
for my kids to get attached to other
partners who might not end up sticking
around at first we mostly dated people
who are in similar situations to ours
who already had nesting Partners a
partner whom they live with and their
own lives to worry about
telling you man the kids are the victims
in situations like this but that changed
with Ty who was single when we met we
started dating in 2018 in 2020 right
before the pandemic the five of us moved
in a new house together we all had been
spending a lot of time together before
moving in but we all bunkered down at
home together during the pandemic and
bonded in a really special way and spent
so much time together soon my kids began
to think of Ty as a parent too so this
is how they make it work
parenting while polyamorous might seem
complicated but having multiple adults
in the house while raising children is
actually a dream come true for her it is
yeah I wonder I wonder what he feels why
are we asking him questions at all it's
always revolving around her in this
article so far
anyway someone is always around to watch
the kids yeah she's got an extra
babysitter
and there are plenty of people to do
chores okay so now she has betas to do
her uh chores around the house
especially since my kids are older we
have our Specialties she says I like to
create meal plans and cook time manages
laundry
[Laughter]
[Music]
dude was brought in to babysit housekeep
and maybe have some bedroom fun Daniel
does the dishes
D takes out the trash and d h by the way
are the kids they don't mention the kids
names
D takes out the trash and H feeds the
pets oh and there's another benefit to
multiple adults Under One Roof three
incomes I bet that works out swell for
her right
we are a close group however Ty and I
both have separate long distance
partners
Ty and I both have separate it starts to
get confusing so Ty is the new guy who
has another guy or girl that he's or she
dating I don't know whatever uh Daniel
who's her
I guess husband has a girlfriend here in
Richmond who doesn't live with them
since we date separately there's always
someone at home with the kids to
maintain a sense of stability okay so
she ended up cucking this new guy to
look after the kids while her and the
husband go out banging other people
imagine being that kid in that household
you know like this can't be good for
children
and though there are more schedules to
juggle we've gotten the hang of it over
time I'm a loyal devotee of Google
Calendar oh well done you should pat
yourself on your shoulder into which we
enter all of our plans
oh so this is a couple here so this is a
stock photograph up here of what I guess
what we thought Ty Jennifer and Daniel
or is it them
why does this chick look totally
different from this chick over here
oh no it's the same one she's got the
tattoo over here on the chest it is the
same one okay so this is the three of
them here
for some reason Felix a little more fit
over here I guess with me I don't know
my older photograph or something like
that but here's the two guys that she's
uh with
they're they're never alpha males never
like
this guy doesn't look like he could
punch his way out of a wet paper bag
I don't know what this guy's doing it's
just I don't know this is weird when I
casually date which is rare I'm always
upfront about family being my priority
my time being limited and only serious
Partners I had a pretty bad breakup
we're in a girlfriend of mine who was
also a mom cut off all contact between
her families ignored attempts to reach
out
uh although Thai is not a biological
parent of my children he will legally
get guardianship and all my Assets in
the unlikely event that someone
something happens to me Daniel he has
also sworn there for my kids even if we
break up but so far that seems unlikely
we're really happy
anyway so this is like the standard
narrative like I mentioned they try to
sell you oh it works out it works out so
well you know we're a poly relationship
I you know Ty does the dishes and Daniel
does uh whatever uh change the light
bulbs and it's like you know they sell
you the story plus we have three incomes
in a household now which is great
because we can barely afford housing so
this is a great thing and this is
something that you two should also
consider is allowing your wife to bring
some other dude into the bedroom and you
share your wife uh and expose your kids
to this hey guys I really hope that you
enjoyed that short clip if you did
consider supporting the creation of
content by checking out my supplement
line pinned in the top comment below of
this video in the comments there's a
link to the unpluggedalpha.com forward
slash shop when you click through you'll
be able to land over here and the entire
lineup is broken down by category that
it performs best in estrogen metabolism
fat burning your foundational Essentials
for health immune Health performance and
testosterone support if you check out
with coupon code Alpha 10 you'll get 10
off on your first order there's also the
option to use the Subscribe and save
model or regular shipments will be sent
over to you on a regular basis and that
gives you a little bit of a discount and
your supplement facts are always broken
down over here thanks for watching I
hope you guys have an awesome day and
again check out that link it's pinned in
the top comment below in this video
peace out